so you grow up where toronto okay yeah
your dad is a harvard guy yeah that's a
brilliant guy my dad got a scholarship
to harvard he came from nowhere in like
the plains of manitoba is it hard
growing up being the son of a guy who
got a scholarship to harvard do they
always throw it in your faces every
minute you know your father got a
scholarship and he did everything
he worked hard and he had nothing it was
implied right
yeah but if he went to harvard he should
have been able to give you everything i
know but he understood i tell you the
greatest favor the the greatest gift my
dad gave to me was i grew up
fairly well-off i didn't grow up like
rich like a billionaire like why why
wasn't he wealthy if he was a harvard
guy what did he do he was he was a
corporate lawyer for many years and then
he was ceo of molson he ran the beer
company yeah he was the ceo of mueller
he was ceo
that's like running the country yes yes
and it's and it's great and uh but he's
he's not that kind of like cigar chomp
and ceo type guy didn't play golf right
in a lot of ways this is crazy that i'm
drawing this comparison he's very much
like you in his personal life thank you
which is i'd like to run molson no but
you could you probably could but he was
you know he he he he took uh uh uh
intellectual pursuits you know he read
and he did stuff and whatever you don't
drink do you i don't drink ironically
your dad ran molson yeah did he drink
he he did he he has at certain times but
he's a very uh moderate guy that's the
thing
my dad is just a moderate guy he did
things in moderation and the greatest
gift i was going to say is that he
always made me work he was like you got
to work so i went to school with all
these rich and then he'd always say you
got to go where so i worked at the
airport as a baggage handler i dug
ditches up in northern manitoba i wanted
you to have a sense of responsibility
and i was outraged believe me when you
have a father
who's a harvard educated guy yeah
running multi is a successful guy
do you announce to your family i want to
go out to hollywood and be an actor uh
no
well were they disappointed in you i
think that there was that i'm i
guarantee you i i will give credit a lot
of credit to my parents for not saying
you're a [ __ ] loser you're a
douchebag yeah you're an idiot
uh and i did say to my dad like look i
think that i want to be an actor and by
the way everybody wants to be an actor
like yeah okay i want that gig get in
line were you a kid who acted in high
school did you little plays a little bit
yeah so there was a little bit of
legitimacy to my you know uh desire to
go out there but still it was like who
the hell and i know that everybody i
grew up with in toronto was like guess
who's going down to new york old loser
pants so for you to go do this took a
lot of balls yeah i didn't know one i
moved to new york i didn't know one
person right and you didn't ask your
parents for money i'd take it you know
go and do these shitty jobs that you
know you didn't particularly like yeah
and what do you do you start studying
acting yeah i came down here and i went
to lee strasbourg i thought you know
when i was younger i thought i wanted to
be a serious actor right because
nobody's i was too stupid i was always
like just a goof off and and if somebody
had said hey if you go to chicago you
can do improv or sketch or whatever but
i i was too dumb to ask questions right
i wish i had asked questions when i was
a kid we had someone to guide you i wish
i was associated
my entire life so then i come down here
and i go to uh uh um uh whether lee
strasberg because i want to be like a
man i want to be serious i want people
to take me seriously right and uh and
then everybody just ends up laughing at
what i do so with that kind of husky
deep voice of yours yeah yeah what what
like what kind of commercials do you do
you like you do i do uh i do like uh uh
like gmc trucks we are professional
grade
wow listen to that yeah gmc
well don't come on don't get too good at
it is that how you do it yeah gm but you
don't need my gig but how do you know
how to do that in other words that's not
your normal voice no it's not you put on
a voice but i could yeah you kind of
just drop into it what do you do let me
hear it do something uh you say uh um
you know you might be like uh uh um
gmc
it's not more than you need just more
than you're used to whoa
so that's you but i will say this but
you do stuff like that that's cool and
then you do stuff like do you have thick
discolored or flaky nails and then
that's not cool